welcome to the show everybody yesterday
you probably heard about the tragic
slaughter of a group of Mormons and US
citizens who were traveling in Mexico
near the US border Donald Trump tweeted
about it they were killed in an attack
by a cartel six children three women
died shot while they were in their cars
and then the cars were set on fire some
of the kids were also taken hostages I
believe that's a terrible case obviously
unthinkable and to heap insult on top of
unthinkable tragedy the New York Times
yesterday when when reporting on this
incident and I really believe that this
well it now this is quite a statement so
I know I know it but this might be the
most disgraceful stunt that I can
remember the New York Times pulling and
that's that is saying quite a lot but
they published an article and and here
is their headline or summary of it on
Twitter anyway it says the brutal
killing of nine members of an American
family in northern Mexico on Monday
highlights the long history of religious
fundamentalist settlers in the region
our religion reporter Elizabeth Diaz
details their history back to the early
20th century really New York Times is
that what it highlights it highlights
religious fundamentalism so when you
hear about a cartel attack killing women
and children the first thing you think
about is I wonder what the history of
religious fundamentalism is in Mexico
that is amazing
it's also important to keep in mind in
case you're for whatever reason so
generous that you would want to give the
New York Times the benefit of the doubt
on this you have to keep in mind that to
the media religious fundamentalist is
invariably in insult now I don't think
it necessarily is or should be I think a
religious fundamentalist is literally
someone who follows or subscribes to the
fundamentals of their religion I think
there are people who are called
religious fundamentalists who maybe
aren't but that's to me what a religious
fundamental
that it's not necessarily an insult but
if we're trying to ascertain the times's
motivation what their real intent is
then it's clear that they meant to
insult these people because for the
media fundamentalist is always
pejorative and on top of insulting the
dead
they're also of course completely
deflecting from the real thing that is
highlighted by this story which should
be obvious to everybody and that would
be violence and chaos on the border the
danger posed by drug cartels etc now why
do we think the media doesn't want to go
that direction why don't they want to
talk about that well that's that's
pretty obvious because with our media
everything is ideological they see
everything immediately through an
ideological lens they really can't even
help it it's just how their minds work
now it's not to give them an excuse but
that's just to show how incompetent they
are and how incapable they are of doing
their jobs but they see everything
ideologically and so they just they
cannot admit that this story could it
all be a reflection on why for example
we should be enforcing the border and so
on by the way remember remember how the
media referred to Baghdady the leader of
Isis after he was killed
remember the Washington Post they called
him an austere religious scholar so
Baghdady the leader of Isis was a
religion and I'll steer religious
scholar while these victims of cartel
violence are fundamentalist do you think
the New York Times would ever publish an
article about Isis that you know talks
about the history of Islamic
fundamentalism in the region no they
would they would never do that
so Baghdady religious scholar Mormons
killed by cartels are fundamentalists
think about that okay much to talk about
today including my speech that I gave at
CSU last night in LA and some drama in
the qat when white nationalists decided
to show up and try to derail things
unsuccessfully but they they gave it
their best
also that report in the Federalist that
I mentioned yesterday an interesting
report I promised to talk about that
we're gonna talk about that and Camela
Harris's plan to ensure that kids
basically never see their parents you're
gonna want to hear about this plan that
she's cooked up in this bill that she's
proposing it's really something else so
what gets all that but first a word from
Rock Auto chain stores you know have
think if you go to a chain store they
have different price tiers for
professional mechanics and people who
are do-it-yourself a yourselfers
rockauto.com prices though are the same
for everybody and on top of that best of
all they're reliably low for everybody
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the markets will
bear it's kind of like what airlines do
but with rockauto.com they're not gonna
do that rockauto.com
is for everybody doesn't require
membership or account login very easy to
navigate and it's a family business
serving Auto Park customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules brake parts tail
lamps motor oil you know if you need new
carpet in your car they have that as
well whether it's your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door as I said it's really easy to
navigate the site find exactly what
you're looking for you know that it's
cheap you know you're supporting a
family business so you can't really get
any better than that go to rockauto.com
right now and see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so they know that we sent you again
that's rockauto.com by the way can I
just say before we move on to the main
topics here you know Emma Emma Watson
yeah the actress Emma Watson is catching
a lot of flak today for saying in an
interview I think what was it with the
British Vogue I think was the one of my
favorite magazines I have a subscription
but she said that she's not single she
is self partnered self partnered and
people are making fun of her for this
but first of all can I say if you make
fun of Emma Watson you're making fun of
her spouse too
think about that
and because she is her spouse and it's
it's just wrong to go after people's
spouses okay that's leave the spouses
out of it that's that's my thing also
even though this is New Age
self-absorbed vapid stupid nonsense
I in a way I do at least kind of admire
people maybe admire is not the right
word I I stand in awe of people who can
love themselves this much who can be
this self-absorbed I almost envy it
because for me you know I would never
want to be partnered with myself that
sounds like the worst thing in the world
why would I want to be married and
partnered with myself of all of all the
people me that's why I married someone
who is exactly the opposite of me yeah
they say opposites attract well that is
100% the case in my marriage she's
exactly the opposite of of me in every
way she is bubbly outgoing cheerful
optimistic if you can imagine that just
the opposite in every way so to marry
myself
I mean well well who would want that who
would want to be married to me besides
my wife for some reason so I say
congrats to Emma on her coupling and I
wish her and herself many happy years of
wedded bliss okay so I spoke at CSULA
last night the subject of my talk was
the lefts war on reality and which is a
theme that I talk about a lot on this
show and it's I wrote a book about it
it's because I think it's when it comes
to the culture it's the most important
thing that we can be talking about and
should be talking about and I tried to
go into detail about the attempts in our
culture to redefine life marriage and
gender and this is a talk that I've
spent a fair amount of time developing
because my goal I don't know if I you
know this is my goal anyway is for it to
be sort of the definitive response to
every major argument that the Left
presents to justify their positions on
these topics life marriage and gender so
that's a lot to bite off and try to chew
in a 30-minute talk but that's my goal
anyway and you can go to youtube you can
go to Facebook and check it out I posted
it on Twitter as well I mean let's ever
so and I would encourage you to go and
watch the talk and share it with your
friends please but there was some drama
yesterday during the Q&A when a bunch of
white nationalists showed up with
questions that of course had nothing to
do well several of them had nothing to
do with whatsoever with the subject of
the talk which is a shame again because
it's an important subject and their goal
was to try to trap me and get me to say
something that they could use against me
to destroy my career and so forth that's
the goal now for a little background on
this
these white nationalists have been
involved in a little campaigning over
the last few weeks to try to crash the q
a's of conservative speakers on campus
doing the left a huge favor in the
process and asking questions that are
often tinged with anti-semitism and
racism again the goal here for them is
to try to trap us
these aren't serious questions and they
are being honest in their approach and
and they know it and we know it and
everyone knows it
this is their this is not an honest
exchange and that's not what they're
looking to do this is just a game of
gotcha now
they were especially excited to show up
for me for two reasons one is that I
work for a Jewish man and that if you
know if you're a white nationalist that
is I suppose an unforgivable sin and
that's why they're they're a cult leader
this guy named Nick Fuentes you know he
called me a race traitor because I work
for Jews and he was very upset about
that so in fact the very first question
of my Q&A took me to task for that
scandalous fact but I work for a Jewish
person and you can go again to YouTube
and see it and they also don't like me
because as I said this Nick Floyd this
guy there cult leader went off on this
onion
rants about me after calling me a race
traitor and so on and the thing that
provoked it was interesting what
provoked it is you know I didn't had
never even heard of this guy I never
said anything about him what provoked it
is that I called him you may remember
this a few weeks ago after the el paso
mass shooting carried out obviously by a
racist who was murdering Hispanics I
called the mass shooter a racist piece
of s white trash some other choice
descriptions that you think we could all
agree given that this is a mass shooter
who killed a lot of people he's an evil
man and there's really nothing you could
say about him that would be beyond you
know it would be out of bounds I think
once you're a mass shooter it's pretty
much a fair game anyone can say whatever
they want about you but foreign tastes
didn't like that and he you know he was
very upset that I was making fun of a
mass shooter that hurt his feelings for
some reason and he responded by calling
me a race traitor who works for Jews
among other choice descriptions and I
responded to him with the level of
seriousness that was appropriate given
his original line of attack and and here
we are and there they were at the qat
though again it's not just mine they're
showing up too and that's important to
note that this is a broader campaign to
essentially undo and undermine all the
inroads conservatives have made in
recent years on college campuses which
are significant now I'm not going to say
that conservatives have achieved some
sort of definitive final victory on
college campuses that obviously is not
the case we there's quite a lot we're
working against you know the the the
institution is against us academia
obviously is against us and academia is
of course in many ways a brainwashing
mechanism taking these malleable
impressionable young people and forming
them into far-left people who believe in
gender theory and all these other things
and so we're working against that and
doing what we can to make progress given
all of that
but what these white nationalists want
to do is they want to come and offer a
big assist to the left by undermining
that and turning all of our talks or
trying to turn them into an opportunity
to spout white nationalist talking
points which again only helps the left
see only people who are helped by it now
if you go and watch the Q&A section of
this talk you'll see two things so what
you see are our UFC ideology and you see
tactics now first to the ideology these
people are convinced that our struggle
in this country is racial and ethnic and
our main goal as they see it is to
preserve our racial ethnic European
heritage in fact these people seem that
from the way they talk about it it seems
as though they think we live in Europe
they talk about us as if we are Europe
as if there's really no distinction
between US and Europe which of course is
not the case and to the extent that
these people are being at all sincere in
what they're saying the one correct
thing they have noticed is that as I
tried to express last night
we do need a unifying principle as a
country and you can't I've said this
many times you can't have a country or a
bunch of people are randomly living in
the same geographic area but they don't
have anything in common that's that's
not a real country that's just not how a
country works if you want to be a
country a people then there must be
something that unifies you and we should
be able to say you know if I say being
an American means blank everyone should
be able to fill in that blank with
something other than living in this part
of the world okay that's not how we
should fill in the blank now it's easy
to say that we should unite as people do
we need to have unity but unite around
what is the question here though is
where these white nationalists go
horribly wrong our unifying principle
isn't and was never
ethnic our unifying principle is the
doctrine upon which our country was
founded our country is unique in the
fact that it was founded on a doctrine
that's not how most countries are
established ours was and it is a
doctrine ok this this idea of inhale
inalienable rights human rights endowed
by a creator that that's doctrinal and
so I would argue that that that should
be our unifying principle and that
doctrine is not a racial one in fact it
is expressly non-racial it is about the
inherent dignity and inherent rights of
all people and as conservatives many of
our most crucial and important arguments
that we make also are hinged on this
concept about the inherent rights and
dignity of all of all people in my talk
last night I spent about the first
twenty minutes of it talking about
abortion and the pro-life fight and
engaging with the pro-abortion arguments
and the pro-life position is is starts
with this fact that all people have
inherent rights and human dignity if
we're wrong about that then there's no
reason to be pro-life and there's no
reason to be conservative there's no
reason to care about any of this stuff
actually now it's true that our founders
did not quite apply that principle
equally as they were blinded by the
bigotries of their time but we can imply
it equally or at least try and that's
our principle in my view but the
questioners weren't satisfied with
straightforward questions and answers
they you know they mainly wanted to lay
traps so they threw gotcha questions at
me about been hoping they could get me
to disavow him because he's Jewish
one guy in particular was very
determined to get me to call him a bigot
this was an interesting exchange he very
much wanted me
the questioner wanted me to call him the
questioner a bigot and he kept insisting
on it over and over again it's very
strange and there are people in the
audience that were you could see their
expression they were kind of perplexed
like why are you why are you so set on
this why do you want to because this is
what he really wanted now why did he
want this well because in my talk I had
just said that in fact I ended my talk
by saying that we should engage with
opposing views rather than just labeling
them bigoted which doesn't mean that
there's no such thing as a bigoted view
calling somebody a race traitor because
they work for Jews is a bigoted view if
that's not bigoted then the word bigger
that just has no meaning at all but it
does have a meaning that's bigoted but
rather than if someone expresses a point
of view especially they're talking about
a topic an issue okay rather than just
saying that's bigoted you should try to
address it because simply even if there
are such things as bigoted points of
view which there are simply labeling
something bigoted is not the same as
debunking it or defusing it so this guy
wanted me to say that he's a bigoted
that he's a bigot so that he could take
the clip put posted on Twitter and
accused me of hypocrisy and cowardice
even if he had to do it out of context
doesn't matter he just wanted me to say
it so he could use it and that's that's
the tactic now I didn't play his game I
didn't give him what he wanted but of
course that still didn't stop him from
going to social media accusing me of it
anyway
in fact as I was leaving the the talk
and you know I spent about 40 minutes on
the talk thirty minutes of Q&A as I was
leaving this guy came out and started
shouting behind me why did you call me a
bigot even though I didn't he just
really wanted me to but they have no
problem lying and and being dishonest if
it advances their ends this is nothing
new you know this is moral relativism
and that's the main point I want to make
here about these these P
that they are moral relativists and
that's very clear in the way they go
about things they did the truth doesn't
matter to them being honest doesn't
matter makes no difference
they have no ethic or ethical or moral
concerns at all none of that matters
it's just you know ends justify the
means and and that's it but this is
nothing new you know I've been dealing
with moral relativists my whole career
they come in different forms they say
different things they pursue different
though not that different ends but
really they're all the same in the end
what it comes down to it and after this
particular group of fringe weirdos fade
out or grow up and move on which which
they probably will eventually they'll be
followed by another group and and
another and another especially in our
culture these days with moral relativism
as it is one of the great scourge is of
our culture and it will just keep going
on and on and all we can do is just meet
it in all of its various forms and try
not to grow too weary of it in the
process even though it can get
irritating after a while all right I
wanted to call your attention to an
article in The Federalist written by
Chad Felix Greene who does a lot of
great work and I should also mention I
think it's relevant to mention that
Greene is a gay man and the only reason
I mention that is to head off at the
pass any claim that his work is
motivated by bigotry against the LGBT
community he's in that community now I
know that that won't stop the most
committed identity politics proponents
from accusing him of anti LGBT bias
anyway
but I think rational people can see the
absurdity of that so Greene's report
analyzes this notion that there's an
epidemic of anti-trans violence and you
hear this all the time right
you hear that trans people are being
murdered particularly black trans people
at a much higher rate than the general
population and this means that there's
an epidemic of anti-trans hate crimes
well I've said before that this claim is
certainly false yes
true that trans people are victims of
violent crimes way more often than the
general population that's got nothing to
do with hate crimes and and I've always
known that but Greene decided to really
do the legwork look at the numbers and
demonstrate it what he discovered is
that first of all the racial angle here
is completely irrelevant the vast
majority of black trans people are
killed by other black people so we can
put that aside race is irrelevant that's
not that's not part of this but what did
what about the murders themselves Greene
discovered that this claim of an anti
trans hate crime epidemic is propped up
by indiscriminately lumping every case
where trans people are killed into one
pile and calling them all hate crimes no
matter the circumstances this is a very
common talk about tactics well here's a
common tactic on the left they do the
same thing with so-called gun violence
where they where they say we have a gun
violence epidemic and then they give you
these really scary numbers what they
fail to mention is that they're taking
every case where a person dies by
gunshot and lumping it into this gun
violence category even though like half
of them are suicides which doesn't mean
that it doesn't matter or it's not a
tragedy it is it's just that it's not
relevant to the point they're trying to
make when they bring up that fact or the
statistics so it's the same thing here
and basically the approach is to pretend
pretend that it's impossible that a
trans person could ever be killed for
any other reason because if a trans
person is killed they're taking that
they're putting it into this to the into
the pile and they're saying these are
all hate crimes and so you end up with
absurdities like for example a trans
person who was one victim among many and
a mass shooting and was included in the
number or another trans person who was
accidentally shot by a friend that's put
in with the numbers many of the deaths
can be attributed to prostitution or
other other risky behaviors
prostitutes in general are murdered at a
much higher rate than everybody else
which is a terrible
but it's not because of hate crimes it's
because of the nature of what they're
doing and who they're dealing with in
the process it's a horrible thing it's
not a hate crime epidemic so green
concludes that out of 118 cases of trans
motors four of them four could be
considered actual anti-trans hate crimes
and that's over the course of four years
so that do the math there that would be
an average of one anti-trans hate crime
a year one and that is what the left
says is an epidemic but this is the game
they make a claim like this and they
just assume you're not gonna look into
it
in fact they demand that you don't look
into it saying that it would be
disrespectful to do so and I guarantee
there's gonna be people saying that even
what I'm saying right now this the very
fact that I'm doing a segment on this is
transphobic and terrible and
inappropriate and all of that so they
make the false claim and then they use
emotional blackmail to prevent you from
trying to confirm it so we just have to
take their word for it but why does it
matter though
I mean why bother debunking this well
first of all because the truth matters
and nobody has the right to lie
unchallenged second this completely
false claim about anti-trans hate crimes
is used to silence people all the time
because invariably whenever the subject
comes up about gender and sex and you
dare to claim that men are men and women
are women
somebody's gonna rush in and start
screaming about anti-trans hate crimes
and claiming that you're encouraging
more bigoted violence against trans
people it all I mean it really always
happens that way if you have if you have
a discussion about these issues for long
enough someone is gonna bring that up
and accuse you of contributing to this
supposed epidemic and if you say there
is no epidemic of bigoted violence
against trans people they say that
you're encouraging it again just by
saying that and
that of course is the game but it is
just that a game that is completely
dishonest and we shouldn't fall for it
all right before we get to emails
Camilla Harris has introduced a bill so
use introduced a bill that would extend
the school day by three hours my god she
wants a 10 hour school day I am so glad
I'm not a kid anymore for so many
reasons I'm so glad that I'm not a kid
in this in this culture in this society
it's just it and then this is definitely
in the top five reasons now let me read
from the week this is their article they
say the presidential Camilla Harris
presidential hopeful is introducing a
bill that will extend the school day
from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. Mother Jones
reports that might elicit groans from
kids but upon closer review the bill
isn't really making them sit at their
desks and learn long division all the
way through this afternoon instead
Harris is helping to better accommodate
families who are burdened by working
hours that don't line up with the
typical school day that ends at 3:00
p.m.
Harris's bill would introduce so if
they're not doing long division for
those three hours what are they doing I
got that apparently is not clear but she
does want to keep them in school anyway
for those for those three hours
Harris's bill would introduce a pilot
program that gives money to 500 schools
serving a high proportion of low-income
families those schools would adjust to
the new hours only closing four weekends
federal holidays and emergencies to make
it easier for parents to balance work
and childcare the program structure is
reportedly purposely vague and will
allow for parents teachers and community
members to weigh in on the best
practices during the first year let's
see she did supposedly scooted students
wouldn't be forced to spend all the
extra time in the classroom but how
would they spend it I guess that's not
exactly clear yet either way point is 8
8 a.m. to 6 p.m. is how she wants to
extend school day this is in kamila
Harris's view apparently she just I
guess doesn't think that kids should
spend really any time around their
families during the school during the
week because I you know I'm I haven't I
didn't see this but I assume that part
of her bill does not include abolishing
homework I assume she's not doing that
so presumably we're talking about 8 a.m.
to 6 p.m. for the school day and the
kids still come home with homework so
you know they get home they leave right
in the morning first thing get on with
6:00 p.m. eat dinner off to do your
homework and then it's bedtime I mean do
you have any time to you know sit around
with your family play a board game talk
to your parents and you know if you have
any time for recreation with your family
which is very important for kids any
time for that know this I think is one
of I mean probably the the main problem
of many without with the school with the
public education system as it is already
currently structured and this is without
even adding on the three extra school
hours of the school day where it
separates kids from their families for
exorbitant amounts of time and starting
earlier and earlier in life you know
when I was a kid most people maybe you
went to preschool when you were four
four or five and then five to six you
started kindergarten now though you know
they've got pre pre pre K they've got
kids going into this the starting school
when they're like three and so starting
at the age of three until they graduated
about eighteen fifteen years they're
gonna be in the government education
system and they're going to spend at
least during the school year they're
going to spend most of their time most
of their waking hours will be spent in
that system under the care of teachers
of government employees you know with
their peers instead of with their
families and with their parent
that is a horrible idea and it's it has
had horrible a disastrous impact on our
culture it's also it's a
self-perpetuating problem because
Camille Harris will say well okay but
you've got all these parents who are
working and and you know they're not
gonna be able to take care of their kids
anyway and so it will be easier for them
just keep the kids in school but the
more and more that the government
education system intrudes into the lives
of kids and takes over the role of
parenting the more it does that the more
you have parents relying on that and
structuring their work schedule around
it and so it's self-perpetuating just
makes it worse and worse so you could
say it's kind of a chicken or egg they
can say oh we're only doing this because
the parents need us to but I think
another way of looking at is the parents
need you to because this is what you're
doing this is the system you've created
and a lot of people have grown addicted
to it and dependent upon it but it's a
bad system and it should be going the
other way we should be trending in the
direction of kids spending less time in
school there should be less time in
school the school day should be shorter
there should be less homework because
the most important thing for a child in
their formative years is to be or
certainly one of the most important
things is for them to be with their
families that kids need that in order to
grow into functional well-adjusted
adults so the trend should be cutting
down on busy work cutting down on time
spent in school that's just wasted
anyway and having parents doing more I
mean because think about how much time
is already wasted in the school day when
I went to school it was yeah I think was
about usually 8:00 to 3:00 basically and
I would say in that chunk of time maybe
two hours was spent productively and the
rest of it was wasted you know the rest
was wasted on on you know thing I mean
you you you'd have kids you'd have
unless of course there are many teachers
that do this now you have you know you
go to class and the teacher puts on a
movie or something I can remember times
when in English class or something we
would spend an entire week watching a
movie in these little 30-minute chunks
just a total waste of time and if you're
gonna be doing that then the kids might
as well be home with their families
what's the point of this so we should be
paring it down less time at school more
time with the families but that's not
what on the left and with with status
like Camilla Harris she wants to go very
much in the other direction all right
let's go to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Mike says hey Matt I love
the show I'm grateful for all the work
you guys are doing at the Illawarra your
talk yesterday was fantastic I'm sorry
the Q & A was hijacked by self-indulgent
children what do you think the source of
this division is and what can be done to
push through it and ensure that the
right ideas persevere hope the family as
well god bless well I think I touched on
that already what what's the source and
I think a lot of it is just sort of
moral relativism in its various
different forms and rearing its head
wearing various different masks and this
is this is the latest mask that it's
wearing this white nationalist stuff and
you know also I don't want a sort of
simpler level you mentioned
self-indulgent children I mean also it's
just a hunger for attention they're
looking for attention
and you might say that I've given it to
them in this show maybe that's a mistake
maybe it is I mean that's there's a
balance that you have to strike here
because on one hand if people are wrong
about something I believe we should
engage and explain why they're wrong I'm
a big believer and that's why I spend
all my time trying to do basically on
the other hand when people are begging
for attention you don't want to go out
of your way to give them attention so
that's the that is the tension that is
the
the balance that has to be struck this
is from Marlene says hey Matt want to
see you today at Cal State LA didn't get
to ask my question read your speech but
sending it to you here in case you can
get to it Thanks yeah there were marlene
there were a lot of people that had
questions related to the talk who didn't
get a chance to ask their question and a
lot of people who wanted to challenge me
on what I said in the talk and didn't
get a chance to do that which is
unfortunate I understand the importance
of a two-parent household and how this
is the best the best for the well-being
of the children specifically a
two-parent household where the parents
are married and stay married I agree
that neither father nor mother are in
our disart are dispensable to raising a
child I believe from your speech your
position is that same-sex couples should
not be able to adopt for the two
statements above my question is is there
any option for individuals who really
really longed to be parents and are gay
I myself have no kids but would love to
someday listening to your speech just
made me think of individuals who really
want to have kids and are gay in your
opinion are they just doomed to not be
parents kind of sad I was thinking maybe
they can have a baby with someone like a
friend of the opposite sex and raise the
baby together but then this would not be
the same again I agree with children
needing a mother and father but I'm
hesitant to bring this up in the
conversation because I feel bad
basically saying if you're gay and
really want to be a parent that just
shouldn't happen for you
yeah Marly well I mean it's always sad
when people want kids and don't have
them or can't have them but as I said in
my talk and as you alluded to I think
every child has a right to a mother and
a father not every child will get that
sadly speaking of sad things okay that's
very sad there there are children who
mother and father divorce or one of the
parents dies or something so not every
child gets it but I think every child
should and so that should be our goal
and if we have kids in the adoption
system and we're looking for parents for
them then we should try to find parents
where it's a mother and a father so that
those
so that those children get what they
need and what they have a right to and
so when it comes to adoption I think we
need to focus on we're talking about
rights as it pertains to adoption it is
the rights of the children that we
should be talking about and focusing on
this idea of prospective parents
prospective adoptive parents having a
right to adopt to me is bizarre and kind
of disturbing because what you're
effectively saying is that those
prospective parents have a right to one
of those children as if those children
are commodities that they have a right
to own and I don't think it works that
way
I think the rights are with the kids in
that situation as far as gay couples who
really want children I you know I it is
a sad thing but there are listen I also
think that you see some of these
Hollywood celebrities as single single
women who go out and adopt without
without a husband just on their own I
don't think they should be able to do
that and I appreciate that they really
want kids and you know I'm sympathetic
to that I am but I don't think as a
single adult you should buy I think it
should be against the law I don't think
you should be allowed to go on an
adopted kid for this reason that that
that's a child that's not gonna have a
father and I think the child has a right
to a father and I don't think that you
know we should take an opportunity away
from a mother father household by
allowing a single parent to adopt a
child which doesn't mean that you know
if you are a single parent with a child
that you're an unfit parent or your kids
are gonna be your the kids lives are
gonna be ruined right it's not what I'm
saying
I'm just saying that the I think maybe
hopefully we could agree that the ideal
scenario in principle would be for a
two-parent household and so when we have
a when we have children in the adoption
system we should be looking for the
ideal scenario and despite popular
misconceptions
there are a lot of prospective parents
hopeful parents who you know who our
mother and father two-parent households
who are who have been waiting for a long
time to adopt a child and so I think
that's what we should be focused on we
can we can have sympathy you know we can
sympathize with people's situations and
we can feel bad for their struggles I'm
I agree we should we should have
compassion but that doesn't mean that we
should compromise by depriving a child
of something that that child needs okay
let's see from Ryan says dear supreme
bearded overlord while I do agree with
you that it's tacky to request a
stranger to give up a comfortable
airline seat for a middle seat on a
flight I think the ultimate culprit here
is Southwest Airlines they create this
unholy debacle every single flight by
not having assigned seating with
assigned seating you're always seated
next to your travel companion and are
able to upgrade your individual seat if
one of them is available having flown
Southwest many times and fallen a
hapless victim to their seating policy I
cannot help but feel that Southwest has
culpability in this outrageous seating
disaster my question to you is when you
take over the world what will your
mandatory airline seating policy be yeah
Southwest I mean I like Southwest
everyone likes Southwest because of
their customer service it's they
definitely blow every other airline out
of the water as far as that goes I even
though their seating policy led to this
disastrous scenario that I suffered
through and frankly was traumatized by a
few days ago I and I know a lot people
complain about it I generally am in
favor of it only because it gives you
some control it it's it's sort of
exciting and it gives you a little bit
of control over whether or not someone's
gonna sit next to you whether you're
gonna get someone in the middle seat
like if you're in an aisle seat there's
a sort of chess match that goes on where
you're trying to figure out where to sit
on the plane exactly to it so as so as
to increase the likelihood that no
we'll sit next to you in the middle seat
and so that little chess match that goes
on and even though I failed in this
particular situation usually I'm pretty
good at that
and I kind of enjoy it so that's
exciting gives you a little bit of power
and control and so I'm in favor of their
seating policy actually from Rachel says
dear dear great and future ruler of all
of our pathetic lives I have already
accepted my death by your order due to
my possession of eight throw pillows but
hopefully your answer may prove
salvation for others if a fan were to
see you in public what is an acceptable
and non wrath inducing way which in
which we may express our appreciation of
your great wisdom is it acceptable to
ask for a picture may someone shake your
hand is a simple knowing nod all that
you will endure of us can disposing of
my pillow save me in the great day of
your ascension great question Rachel I
appreciate that these are the kinds of
questions I should have gotten in the
queue a future reference so I think the
procedure for speaking to me in public
is is pretty simple pretty standard
basic etiquette really you know it's
it's not a big deal all you have to do
is just lie prostrate on the ground army
crawl towards me face down then as you
get close to me you may reach out your
hand towards my foot don't make contact
obviously if I kick you then that's a
sign that I don't want to speak to you
you must immediately roll away from me
without looking up if I say rise and
speak you may stand don't make eye
contact look towards the floor and pay
me a compliment lasting no less than 30
seconds but no more than two minutes and
then turn around about-face and walk
away and that's it you know it's I mean
pretty pretty somebody and that's and
that's just really being polite I think
but I appreciate that that question
Rachel and thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there